>>> TONIGHT, CNN LEARNING
COUNSEL JACK SMITH HAS
SUBPOENAED OFFICIALS IN
ALLEGHENY COUNTY, PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS IS PART OF HIS CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE 2020 ELECTION.
NOW, ALLEGHENY COUNTY CARRIES
SIGNIFICANCE BECAUSE IT HAPPENS
TO BE WHERE THE FORMER TRUMP
LAWYER RUDY GIULIANI ARGUED IN
FEDERAL COURT THAT THE ELECTION
WAS STOLEN.
BACK WITH US NOW, FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE LAWYER TY COBB.
AS ALWAYS, I APPRECIATE YOUR
INSIGHT.
AND THIS IS NOW MOVING SO
QUICKLY HERE.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL JACK SMITH
HAS BEEN SENDING OUT SUBPOENAS
TO LOCAL OFFICIALS NOW IN ALL
SEVEN STATES WHERE TRUMP ALLIES
HAD PUT FORWARD A SLATE OF FAKE
ELECTORS.
AND HE'S DONE THAT INCREDIBLY
QUICKLY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HE'S FOCUSED
ON?
>> I THINK HE'S FOCUSED ON BOTH
THE POTENTIALLY CORRUPT EFFORTS
TO INFLUENCE THE WAY THAT THE
STATES WERE ASKED TO ACT BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THROUGH
INDIVIDUAL CONTACT SUCH AS THE
LONG RECORDED PHONE CALL WE HAVE
WITH SECRETARY STATE
RAFFENSPERGER IN GEORGIA AND
THROUGH THE LAWSUITS WHERE I
THINK HE WAS OVER 64, AND IN
TERMS OF DISMISSALS, AND MANY
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN PUNISHED OR
REFERRED FOR ETHICAL VIOLATIONS
IN CONNECTION WITH THOSE.
I THINK HE IS NOW -- HE'S GOT,
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, CURRENT
COUNT 20 OR 20 PLUS PROSECUTORS
INVOLVED.
AND I THINK THEY ARE, TO THEIR
CREDIT, DOTTING ALL THE Is AND
CROSSING ALL THE Ts.
JANUARY 6th ITSELF AND THE
EVENTS OF THE CAPITOL, WE HAVE
TO REMEMBER ARE REALLY -- WHILE
THEY ARE THE MOST DRAMATIC
INDICATION OF TRUMP'S DISRESPECT
FOR DEMOCRACY, THEY AREN'T THE
ONLY WEAPON THAT HE ATTEMPTED TO
USE IN HIS EFFORTS TO CLAIM TO
POWER.
AND I THINK THE COMBINATION OF
ALL THOSE EFFORTS TO CLAIM TO
POWER IS THE FUNDAMENTAL
CONSPIRACY THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS HOMING IN ON.
>> SO I WANT TO ASK YOU A FOLLOW
ON THAT.
BUT FIRST, BECAUSE WE'RE JUST
DAYS AWAY FROM THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE, OBVIOUSLY SEPARATE
FROM THE DOJ CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
BUT THEY ARE SET TO ANNOUNCE
THEIR DECISION ON CRIMINAL
REFERRALS TO THE DOJ.
SO THEY HAVE COME TO THEIR
CONCLUSION.
HERE'S WHAT WE THINK YOU SHOULD
DO, SEPARATE FROM YOUR OWN
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION THAT
YOU'VE BEEN PURSUING.
SO WE'RE EXPECTING THAT IN JUST
A FEW DAYS.
WE KNOW THEY ARE CONSIDERING A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALONG WITH
OTHERS IN HIS INNER CIRCLE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL FOR TRUMP HIMSELF?
>> I DO NOT.
I THINK THEY STARTED OUT WITH
THAT AS A GOAL.
AND I THINK THEY CERTAINLY HAVE
PUT FORTH EVIDENCE WHICH WOULD
JUSTIFY, EVEN IN THE ABSENCE OF
CROSS-EXAMINATION, WHICH I THINK
IS AN UNFORTUNATE PRODUCT OF THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSTITUTION.
BUT EVEN WITHOUT
CROSS-EXAMINATION, CLEARLY THE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY HAVE PUT
FORWARD JUSTIFIES THEM TO MAKE
CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
THEIR REFERRAL IS LARGELY
SYMBOLIC, OF COURSE.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS NOT
REQUIRED TO DO ANYTHING IN
RESPONSE TO IT.
BUT, YES, I'M SURE THEY WILL FOR
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> DOES THIS GIVE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, I DON'T KNOW, ANY
SORT OF COVER?
DOES IT INFLUENCE THEM IN ANY
WAY?
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS A SPECIAL
COUNSEL NOW, AND HE IS VERY
DOGGEDLY AND VERY QUICKLY
PURSUING HIS OWN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION HERE.
BUT DOES A CRIMINAL REFERRAL
FROM THE COMMITTEE HELP OR HURT
THE DOJ IN ITS INDICTMENT
DECISION?
>> I THINK BOTH.
I THINK IT HELPS THEM WITH
PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW THESE EVENTS
MORE LOCALLY AND CAN LOOK TO
WHAT THEIR CONGRESSMEN ON THE
COMMITTEE DID, AS WELL AS IT
KEEPS THE PRESSURE ON, AND THE
MEDIA KEEPS THE ISSUE FRONT AND
CENTER.
IT'S ONE SHOE THAT DROPPED.
IT DOES COMPLICATE IT A LITTLE
BIT JUST BECAUSE IT MAKES THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SLIGHTLY MORE
VULNERABLE TO CLAIMS OF
PARTISANSHIP.
IF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DECIDES TO CHARGE TRUMP WITH THE
UNPRECEDENTED, UNDEMOCRATIC
CORRUPT EFFORTS TO CLING TO
POWER,